welcome to another video my beloved
weebs today we're going to talk about
redline a movie that can boost your
morale to an unbelievable level so
without any further ado let's get right
into it the film starts with the
featuring of the yellow line car race
the galaxy's famous final elimination
race despite two interplanetary wars
it's the most popular race in the galaxy
the race is taking place on planet
dorothy where aliens with dog-like faces
are waiting for the contestants to pass
through the nearby track the people are
placing bets over various contestants a
portrait machine suddenly comes hovering
over the track to show the live race to
a worldwide audience the scene shifts to
cars that are drifting with tremendous
speed to take the lead in a moment a
horde of racing cars with stylish
designs and big engines dash on the
track leaving the crowd in enormous joy
the commentator introduces the racers
who are mostly aliens however there are
humans in this race too in fact a female
racer is racing the race with her
special racing car
jp who's also known as sweet jp is a
young man who's known for his kind
personality and retro style he's driving
his trans am 20 000 to win the race he
suddenly uses nitro boost to speed up as
he's behind all the races as jp moves
closer to the other races an alien racer
uses a missile to attack his car but he
brilliantly dodges it by slowing down
the crowds watching the race on an
outdoor giant monitor screen in the
desert town of the water stop jp's alien
mobster mechanic frisbee is watching the
televised race with a mafia boss who
constantly massages his gums with
cocaine the gambling boss is concerned
that jv might attempt to win the fixed
race but frisbee reassures him that jp
needs bail bond funds from the payoff on
the track racers continue to use
missiles and weapons to burst jp's car
away the missile hits another car that
blows he dashes through the burning heat
of the destroyed car by using his godly
driving skills
jp attempts to win by using another
nitro boost but frisbee resorts to using
a remote detonated transmitter hidden in
the palm of his hand which the mob boss
doesn't notice causing jp's trans am
twenty thousand to explode thereby
making the crab sanchi si hovercraft
piloted by female racer sonshi cherryboy
hunter mclaren the final winner while
recuperating from the explosion in a
planet dorothy hospital frisbee tells jp
he's off the hook with his bondsman and
gives him a suitcase full of money jp
initially turns him down and throws the
suitcase towards him frisbee opens the
door and a crowd of reporters stormed
the hospital room where jp learns that
he's been voted by popular demand for
the red line due to the drop out of two
races as the race's location is on robo
world a planet dominated by militant
zelot cyborgs whose president has
threatened an interstellar television to
hang all involved with the redline
mothership if it appears out of
hyperspace over their planet jp tells
frisbee to repair his trans am and makes
a statement watch out roboworld here
comes jp the government of robo world
choose to rebel against this race
because the broadcast will be sent over
thousands of satellites that will expose
the secret weapons robo world has built
up against treaties all the races
nominated for the red line board the
ship for departure to robo world upon
reaching robo world satellite all races
get into small space shuttles called
pods the pods are released and races are
sent to europass inside dest tower on
roboworld the president asked secretary
of defense titan for a report about
ships landing on robo world's moon
europass a demilitarized zone that robo
world signed away to refugees in the m3
nebula federation making it off limits
to robo world's troops the president
obtains a verbal oath from colonel
volton to fight to the death to protect
robo world
after arriving on europass jp goes to an
exchange shop he spends all his money on
some cigarettes rides his hoverbike and
leaves for the repair garage while the
racers are staying on europass before
red line under constant media coverage
frisbee's alien junk dealer old man mo
wants to put weapons on the restored
trans am which jp refuses despite his
competitors being armed old man mull
also protests the presence of frisbee on
their team and his insistence on using a
rare uncontrollable hyper-powered engine
but eventually gives in to jp's
persuasion jp finds sanchi in the slow
hours of the oasis restaurant on the
moon the manager serves her a crab-like
dish while jp pulls down his pants to
humiliate him because he was messing
with sonshi jp starts a conversation
with her although she doesn't give him
much attention upon asking she tells him
that her father was a racer and they
used to build cars together and she
inherited his love for cars and racing
she grabs her necklace which turns out
to be a steam light stone that her
father gave her they're interrupted by
shinkai formerly of the robo world army
who shows up at the oasis when racer
little dejuna a recently awol
subordinate of colonel volton attacks
shinkai's partner trava as the fight's
going on the red line favorite machine
head a tall menacing but ultimately
well-mannered cyborg appears and is
attacked by a sobbing little dayzuna
machine head pushes daisuna who ends up
breaking a huge glass of water jp grabs
on she and saves her from the flood muma
colonel volton and his soldiers enter
oasis machine head confronts volton for
being in the demilitarized zone
volton reminds the racer any redline
event will be repelled by the army and
police before leaving the damaged
restaurant as volton's leaving jp moves
forward and mocks him the soldiers hit
him with the back of a gun leaving him
unconscious after regaining
consciousness he drops sanshi to her
capsule hotel he asks her about her
driving force to which she counter
questions him jp leaves a bizarre answer
and she leaves saying good night to him
jp picks up the earring that she's
dropped he experiences a flashback while
holding the earring which tells us that
he met her in his childhood she was
racing in a car and got drifted from the
track but still she didn't give up and
continued the race while crying she
tells jp and his friends to quit
watching and get on the track to
experience the madness and thrill of
racing jp was inspired by her passion
and decided to become a racer jp leaves
while grieving over the fact that she
probably doesn't remember him upon
reaching the workshop maul told him that
he can't work with frisbee because he's
a jerk he also tells him the trz master
engine is too deadly and a normal human
couldn't drive it jp requested him to
get that engine because only that engine
could compete against other fierce
racers moles somehow ends up agreeing to
the request anyway the next day frisbee
tells jp that his race will have the
same drill as last time he must stay at
rare till the third quarter to get his
odds down and then make his way at the
last quarter jp tells him that he'd
rather find another way to make money to
pay for the engine but frisbee tells him
that he can get a spare engine but not a
spare life meaning the mafia boss will
kill him if he doesn't keep his promise
jp bursts off the packet of chips and
leaves frisbee brings jp a test car
installed with an old arz air master
engine he drives the car and pushes it
to full speed the car ends up crashing
but fortunately jp survived the crash
without any major injuries at night jp
gets to see the power of the latest arz
air master engine he was surprised upon
witnessing the raw power of it frisbee
tells him that he'll put together the
rest of the trans ambien tomorrow one
day before the race the commentators of
the race continue to explain the
background of all races meanwhile miners
on roboworld use their power suits to
sabotage the military bases power
station while the race commission which
promotes gambling hires earth native
racing partners lynchman and johnny
boyer to sabotage the orbital
disintegration cannon which secretary
titan plans to use to destroy the
redline mothership the instant it comes
out of hyperspace jp comes to the house
of son shi and leaves her earring with a
flower on her door where she picks up
and smiles he continues to speed up on
his way back home on the hoverbike the
bike crashes while throwing away jp he
experiences another flashback that tells
us how he and frisbee met and how they
built a car with the help of mole to win
the race the flashback also features a
fight between him and frisbee that might
be because of debts the flashback ends
with a cute girl telling him her name is
son she over the broadcast of redline
news soon she gets to know that jp was a
race fixing specialist in the past
while in hyperspace the princess from
the planet supergrass marks the
racecourse on the military base with a
pair of scout vessels with the starting
line to the north at the knockout tower
and the finish line to the south east of
the death tower unaware of the sabotage
against the orbital disintegration
cannon the president realizes the races
are on the planet after the cannon fails
he sends his troops at the races on the
other hand all races are deployed on the
track with their respective cars
igniting the start of the legendary
redline race the racers have an intense
car battle against each other while
taking out the military forces of
colonel volton the president becomes
increasingly desperate as the racers
evade them and approach the mine laid in
zone 7x the lair of a secret illegal
biological weapon named funky boy who
awakens from its stasis as the racers
and the rebellious miners converge on it
with the several hundred foot tall funky
boy awakening and subsequent destruction
of the base coinciding with the orbital
cannon coming back online the president
orders funky boy fired upon the
explosion takes out most of the
robo-world troops while jp pushes to
write his overturned car off its side
and rescue the hot babe she asks him
about his past as a race fixer he tells
her that frisbee got involved with the
mafia to get better parts as they were
winning the races and ended up getting
framed in a mafia mess upon crackdown by
the police sanchi her vehicle totaled
agrees to rider them to the finish line
as funky boy regenerates colonel volton
had to dangerously merge with another
bioweapon which turned him into an ugly
monster so he could fight and defeat the
funky boy
frisbee watches the race on several
televisions parked atop a mesa in the
mob boss's giant cadillac hovercraft
where he revives the same deal as yellow
line frisbee however refuses to detonate
the explosive charge this time wanting
to see his friend win the big one just
one time he's attacked by aliens for his
decision but is saved by old man mole
who discovers frisbee sabotage and
shoots and kills the mob boss and his
lackeys with a double barrel for a ship
firing shotgun as the race nears the
finish line machine head and jp race to
the southern line boosted by their rare
steam-like boosters as they come to a
desperate neck and neck finish the
drunken old man mull accidentally
detonates frisbee's remote detonator
propelling jp and son she towards the
finish line thrown from their vehicle
the boost is enough and jp wins by the
length of his long ducktale pompadour as
the racers rest at the end of the race
amidst the ruins of robo world jp and
sanchi float down to the ground kissing
and thus declaring their love for each
other machine head who vowed to win
becomes second sees the romance and his
rage turns to laughter happy with the
outcome anyway the other races who all
survived as well laugh with him as
they're all so happy with the outcome so
this is it for today's video if you like
the video give it a huge thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel for more videos
farewell till next time